das ist eigentlich ein biergarten im
norden von washington dc wo sich sonst
am wochenende freunde auf ein bier
treffen werden nun tüten gepackt tüten
voller lebensmittel und anderen
nützlichen produkten die barkeeperin
kellner alle angestellten haben hier in
kürzester zeit ein hilfsnetzwerk
aufgezogen für menschen die wenig haben
auch wenn eigentümerin einer selbst
nicht recht weiß wie es weitergehen soll
viele restaurants aber besonders spaß
machen nur wenig reinen gewinnen niemand
hat irgendwelche notfall rücklagen für
eine situation wie diese also versuchen
wir gerade unser geld so zu verteilen
dass wir vor allem unsere mitarbeiter so
lange wie möglich beschäftigen können
das junge team einige auch mit hohen
studienkrediten sind auf den job
angewiesen
ich habe erst vor kurzem hier angefangen
vor vier tagen in zeiten von corona wo
ausgehen und gesellig sein nicht geht
sind ihre jobs besonders gefährdet ich
war zwei monate lang arbeitslos ich weiß
wie sich das anfühlt ich möchte dafür
sorgen dass andere versorgt sind und
sich über wasser halten können wer weiß
wie lange das andauern und nicht nur
care-pakete es gibt sogar warme
mahlzeiten hier im hinterhof haben sie
dafür einen kühlwagen und eine mobile
küche aufgebaut aber auch andere
restaurants helfen mit
viele restaurants haben ihre frischen
lebensmittel gespendet nachdem sie
schließen mussten
außerdem haben in der eventbranche viele
leute fahrzeuge die jetzt rumstehen und
denen nun aber die spenden abgeholt
werden können tyler ist eigentlich
geschäftsführer einer war heute aber ist
der essence lieferant er macht sich auf
den weg um suppe und hunderte
nudelgerichte abzuholen
in der gastroszene gibt es eigentlich
ziemlich viel konkurrenz untereinander
egal ob des restaurants bars gaststätten
oder nachtclubs sind
es ist schön zu sehen wenn alle vereint
sind weil normalerweise geht es immer um
die eigenen interessen heute nicht jetzt
nicht mehr
dieser laden musste ausschließen möchte
aber seine suppe spenden
hier schon mal 25 portionen von omas
nudelsuppe tausend dank kann ich das
einladen und wiederkommen oder muss ich
dann erstmal in quarantäne
anderen helfen aber aufpassen dass man
wenig kontakt miteinander hat das ist
nicht einfach
schumacher will es trotzdem versuchen
wir haben etwas übrig und wollen der
gemeinde helfen
wir sind ein lokales unternehmen und
wollen damit etwas gutes tun
taylor muss weiter auf ihn warten noch
mehrere hundert nudelgerichte die
abgeholt werden wollen
ein italienisches restaurant haben sie
gespendet auch für küchenchef matt steht
künftig die eigene existenz auf dem
spiel
wir dürfen aktuell ja nur essen zum
abholen oder catering anbieten
das läuft einigermaßen aber trotzdem
betrifft ist das team weil sie nicht so
viele schichten wie sonst bekommen das
darf ja nicht mehr bei uns gegessen und
serviert werden
in den usa sind servicekräfte besonders
auf trinkgeld angewiesen
die meisten löhne einfach zu niedrig die
care pakete und das essen sind also auch
für andere service arbeiter gedacht
inzwischen ist hier alles aufgebaut ab
18 uhr darf täglich jeder kommen der
unterstützung braucht immer nur ein paar
menschen auf einmal dürfen den raum
betreten
mitmenschlichkeit füreinander sorgen und
gleichzeitig abstand halten
das versuchen sie hier irgendwie
hinzubekommen
und so werden in diesen tagen
servicekräfte zu krisenmanagern und eine
bahn zur anlaufstelle für all jene die
gerade in not sind